all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show and we just had Charles Woodson
here and we had Roger Staubach here in
the first hour so let's finish the trio
of Heisman Trophy winners right here on
the set put your hands together for
their most recent Heisman Trophy winner
how are you sir you bet
you made the Superbowl here not even
you're not even know I don't even know
if you're gonna be in the league yet or
not I guess we'll find that out yeah
well how we how we been doing here on
the Super Bowl week what you been up to
the fun
sheera Gatorade you know I've been
fortunate enough to be you know part of
the family for some years now so you
know they they keep they keep me keep me
going and I'm just happy to be out here
and know I also know because you know I
he was on the show yesterday a.m. and
I'm a colleague is at the NFL Network
you sat down with Deion Sanders what did
he did he give you any wisdom any words
of wisdom at all no he just said for me
he was just saying you know go with your
heart and you know whatever you do you
know never look but that's really you
know with your heart that was a message
he's kind of changed it a little bit
because a few weeks ago basically he
said grab a back not look back you did
hear that yeah but he did not say that
to you yesterday no we talked about it
okay there so what do you think as
you're sitting here I'm gonna do what I
want to do do just so you do not know
what you're gonna do right now as you're
sitting here right now okay
we're getting closer so you do know what
you're gonna do you just don't want to
reveal it just yet it's what you're
selling if this was yes that's what you
want to say no I don't want to say any
I'm asking you what do you think in your
mind cuz it's I know for sure baseball
would love to have you and so would the
NFL but you would agree though let's
let's start with this would you agree
that you can't do both yeah okay well
I'd love to be a cuz you're playing
quarterback right I mean so that would
be difficult so you know that you're
gonna have to choose one over the other
at some point do you know in your head
when that decision might be coming
closer okay cuz all right so let me ask
you this one
I'm having fun with this outdoor - you
know I I host the combine at the NFL
Network okay okay so will I'd be saying
that's Cuyler Murray down there okay you
don't know that but you do know that
you're just not telling me yet no okay
you know you're here for Gatorade you
know you're for the Super Bowl yeah okay
which what is your favorite part about
playing baseball how about that let's
start right there
does it be a question thank you you
haven't said that to me yet so the other
questions were not as good as what
you're saying no okay
what do you like about playing baseball
Tyler oh I like hitting the ball I mean
I could put it yeah I like I like
getting in the box and just competing
basically you know you're gonna feel
when you play baseball everybody knows
this so this is a rush when you get in
the box for those who may not have seen
you play baseball
obviously America has seen you play
football of much smaller portion of
America has seen you play baseball who
do you model your game after would you
see you model your game after in the
least modest way don't worry about it
just drop a name because we all think
we're great at what we do so go ahead I
really don't have a name for you okay so
what is your game like that uh I really
I feel like I can do it all you know hit
for power head for contact obviously run
fast and you know the more reps you know
the better I'll be now filled so
whatever it is the you know the
organization needs from you I feel like
I built sure so you get on first you can
you can be on third within just a couple
of pitches potentially is what you're
saying
okay put the pressure on the pitch you
put pressure on the defense you know
which obviously you're also used to
doing and the other sport so and then
you can you can pop one out I mean how
many home runs have you had me here
what's your what's your what's your best
home run here uh this past year was -
okay so we hit double digits do you do
you Cadillac around the bases I mean
what's your style no I try not to
disrespect - picture too much
- too much I heard thank you I thought
that - no keep it simple you know I'm
supposed to you know if that's it that's
how I feel supposed to do that so
sometimes if I'm in the mood for it but
that's not too much okay so which of the
five tools is your favorite the most
obvious I feel like it's speed but I
like to hit the ball yeah okay
Carla Marie here on the Rich Eisen show
what's your favorite part about playing
football I'd say just being around the
guys in the locker room yeah building
the bog not about just dropping one in
the bucket touchdown at all that's great
but yeah sure yeah yeah but the
camaraderie of the locker room okay Kyle
Amari here on the Rich Eisen show this
past year for Oklahoma how much were you
in contact with Baker Mayfield
throughout the year Kyler not a lot okay
you know I know he he was busy himself
then he know you know he knows I was
busy so I'm just getting to watch him on
Sunday it's pretty special and I know
you know he was he was doing the same on
Saturday so after you know come around
the heisman time is when you know we
kind of started to talk a lot more it's
a lot more they're out you knew he had
you had to his vote for sure obviously
so what did it mean for you to win the
Heisman Trophy I was dream come true I
mean it's it's still really hasn't
really set in it's weird you know I
don't say my life changed but you know
just everywhere everywhere I go people
notice me stuff like that so something
I've always dreamed of obviously so you
know I'm not surprised by any of the
reactions and stuff like that but it's
definitely a blessing okay and where is
that trophy right now I sleep next to it
it's on your nightstand yeah see it's
good morning Heisman everyday
seriously it's it's right there next to
it like there's a night table next to
the caller Murray's bed in the Heisman
trophies resting yes sir yes sir that's
amazing
have you ever woken up in the middle of
the night and you've had it in your
there's no there's no Heisman spooning I
by the way I would if I won the Heisman
I've only received the Heisman it was
asking for prom dates back in high
school I got the Heisman allotting
Heisman spooning is a great fantasy team
name you got to do that right I mean so
there you go so when it all comes down
to it what was more awkward me trying to
pry an answer out of you five minutes
ago we're sitting next to two and having
his name is pronounced by the guy who
then ha and handed you the Heisman
Trophy
what's more awkward okay good okay
so then give me an ant I mean like
mid-february you think or next week what
do you think will I leave this place
when you leave this there's nothing
about this rule when you leave Atlanta
to somewhere on so next week I don't
know have you been talking to your daddy
or wrong I've talked to everybody oh my
what your dad okay cuz you know
obviously you got guys and boat it is
true right your uncle was your uncle at
the plate yeah he was when Randy
Johnson's fastball blew up the poor bird
that flew in the middle of it yeah he
was what has he told you about that iPad
do you think he was gearing up 400 so
you know I don't know he described it
too much but I could only imagine what
he was thinking right and then the ball
got fouled all you will know the bird
got the ball you know what I mean so the
best advice your dad has given you is
what he's not an advice giver or you
know he just something it's not it's not
like that you know
like we're just sitting there talking
about snow yeah do this to do that no
it's not like this oh okay okay I'm just
trying to figure out I'd love to see you
at the combine that is for darn short
appreciated I would I really would you
know I would love to see you out there
and spin it and see what you could do at
the next level in the National Football
League do I take that as confirmation no
doubt Chris what do we do right that's
right as we've gotten so far every terms
of a possible confirmation and what is
Boer Estonia okay so Gatorade calm use
the promo code Gatorade SB for 20% off
your purchase through February 17th to
get yourself a nice a nice discount on
this but this baby that's right here is
this mind that you're dropping this off
no no you take it you have it give it
back to me in Indianapolis the calamari
on Twitter and Kyler one murray on
instagram put your hands together
tomorrow breeze when we come back some
news so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience